[Music]
christina is with us in cedar rapids
iowa hi christina how are you
oh good how are you dave thanks for
taking my call sure what's up
um so i have a question for you um
we recently paid off um over 300 000 in
student loans wow yeah christina
yeah it took us about four years i'm a
physician
um
and my question is
i just had my third baby
and
i
feel crazy saying this but i don't want
to return to work
um my husband has always been
supportive and working kind of part-time
jobs while
um taking care of the other kids and he
just recently started a full-time job
at a bank and it's kind of a a trait
they're
training him
while he's there and it would be a major
pay cut for me to quit my job but um
that's kind of what i'm feeling told to
do and i just wanted to hear your
thoughts on that
wow
what does that what what is he going to
make at the bank when it's all when the
smoke clears on the train and everything
yeah so they're starting at his job as a
credit analysis and he's kind of a
junior credit analysis so his starting
salary right now is 56 000 a year
and then they told him as soon as
he's kind of fully trained
then um it would be
in the 60 to 70 000 um would be like
where he'd start at cool and what do you
make now
me um if i go back to work i'm making
about 190 000 a year okay
all right so we're dropping our income
120 000 bucks to make this move
yeah
um if you go from 190 to 70 i mean of
course if you if you go back to work
it'd actually be 260 because it'd be him
making 70 plus your 190 but but you're
out of debt and you're able to make it
on 70 000
um yeah we um
our only debt is our house um and our
mortgage what we own it right now is
about 95. we live in a kind of a smaller
rural area 95 000.
um
we're in our mid-30s and our retirement
we have about 230 000 in retirement
um
are you done with it or could you do
telemedicine two days a week or go in
one day i mean are you just completely
burnt
i feel really burnt and it's really hard
to
give my all to my husband and my
children when i always have that stress
on me um we did talk about i have
reached out to a couple um
like the ceos at a few smaller rural
hospitals about the possibility of maybe
doing one or two days a week for them
in the future maybe when the baby our
baby gets to be a little older
but
what have you got to do to keep your
medical license intact
um
i think i just have to maintain my
continued medical education and my
license which yeah my experience with
doctors who
have a picture in their head about
well let me let's choose separate issues
here one is
um a mom who's like i want to go be with
my kids that's that's
that's noble great wonderful high
support would never tell you not to do
that absolutely awesome
the other side that the doctors that
i've worked with and known over the
years
are just
quite frankly wired differently than the
rest of us and the thing that drove them
to go to med school and get through med
school and to get through residency and
rotations
is uh there's just a different drive and
i wonder i've had several buddies who
end up i'm gonna just go i'm gonna quit
all this i'm gonna go do a small
practice
a couple years later they're back doing
a night a week in the er just to get
their blood pumping again right so i
wonder if if you've boxed yourself into
an either or right now and maybe you
need a break but that there are some
other opportunities to split the
difference here
okay yeah i i don't care the money thing
doesn't scare me
what i'm thinking about is um
if i were in your shoes
the thing i would struggle with the most
is not i you know yeah i want you to be
with these kids that's what you want to
do let's just let's lay that as the
foundation of the whole discussion um
but you have paid such a price
of uh commitment and diligence to become
a doctor and then as a doctor to pay off
the three hundred thousand dollars so
you literally paid a price as well
as the as the toll
you have paid to go do nothing with it
for the rest of your life seems extreme
yeah i would agree with that and i think
i think that's what's the hard thing
yeah and i think you're gonna struggle
with that so i i just from uh
you know
from the standpoint of that i'm gonna
stay engaged at a
greatly at a 90 reduced level
or or whatever after the child comes and
after you you know take a normal
maternity leave or whatever but like you
said go hit the rule hospital for a day
or two a week something anything uh or
you know
telemedicine like john suggested or
whatever it is you want to do but
something to just keep um
uh to stay a little bit engaged and the
natural result of that is gonna be a
hundred thousand dollars a year probably
okay i mean you know that's that's your
that's irrelevant because you're gonna
make plenty of money but but um i you
know some kind of part-time something
that fits into your new life that you
want to have with these kiddos
but also allows you to
um not just dust
you know shake the dust off your feet
from all of the
the decade of work you've put into
getting to where you are
i'm i'm sure they exist and they can
write in and let me know i've never met
a doctor who walked away and ended up
staying away because they're that's why
they i mean it takes such uh it's such
an identity i'm a helper that's what i
do um it's hard to just walk away from
that completely well there's just an
intellectual and emotional commitment of
time to stimulation uh like the whole
thing yeah the whole thing so anyway yes
i would quit uh doing what you're doing
and so that you can be with your kids
and yes i would try to find some
uh
greatly reduced middle ground
uh that you can stand on um because i
think you'll be happier
because your intellect is going to
require
uh you know you're going from solving
ultra high level problems high level
thinking to can i have a snack can i
have a snack can i have a snack
and uh it's not that one is better than
the other one is more noble than the
other that's not the point the point is
your brain is set up in a certain way
now and it's it's um yeah
you know uh a lot of moms of little ones
uh while they want to be full-time moms
they also want to have adult
conversations with adults absolutely and
need it and so that that's that's in the
mix here so yeah that's but yes i would
quit i'll quit doing what you're doing i
wouldn't work the hours you're working i
would not stay in the 190 position you
don't have to you can make it on the 70
plus whatever little
plus the other 70 that you bring in or
whatever maybe you can match his now
let's let's talk about the person who
hasn't who's in that situation who
hasn't put in the incredible work that
christina put in to get that money paid
off you're stuck you you're gonna get
yourself out of debt you gotta get
yourself out of that because you're not
in a position to like you can't lay
under a three hundred thousand dollar
blanket yes uh and wait it'll suffocate
you and sleep you won't be able to sleep
that's right and you won't be able to
prosper your family won't be able to
move forward so you you know you've dug
a hole now you gotta get out right and
then you can talk about doing what she's
doing yeah but christina put in four
years of grinding yes they've been
thinking
man they've been hitting it good for you
guys
so well done
very well done